avec le printemps c'est l'éclosion des
campements pour personnes sans abri à
montréal des dizaines de tentes ont été
érigés un peu partout dans la métropole
près de la rue notre-dame à l'impôt ses
briques pour délimiter le terrain sur
lequel il a installé son campement de
fortune jusqu'au mois de juillet il a
demandé l'anonymat craignant les
représailles des autorités pour alain
pas question de se rendre dans un refuge
c'est pas ma tasse de thé on n'a rien
eux - gériez les refuges peuvent en rien
donné j'ai asseyé souvent embarqués dans
leurs programmes ça marche pas mais la
ville de montréal n'a pas l'intention de
tolérer ces campements qui poussent aux
quatre coins de la ville comme ici près
de l'avenue atwater
l'administration plantes dit que les
risques sont beaucoup trop grand pour
ceux qui décident d'y installer leurs
tentes des grands risques incendie elle
était dernière on a évité le pire c'est
pas viable nous on veut que les gens
puissent avoir une toit où passer la
nuit et mais que ces personnes là puis
se rendre au logement au logement avec
de soutien psychosocial nécessaire
jacques rien déjà des expulsions cet été
la solution se trouvait
s'accorder agrémenter sa roi qu'est ce
qu'ils ont besoin ils demandent une plus
grande écoute des différents ordres de
gouvernement est incapable de se trouver
un logement à faible coût n'est pas de
sou studio de solution miracle c'est du
logement avec soutient le dirigeant de
la mission old brewery dénonce cette
politique d'expulsion tout comme la
ville de montréal il réclame à québec
d'offrir davantage de logements
abordables pour aider les gens à se
sortir de la rue pour accompagner des
gens directement de la rue des
campements dans les logements donc faut
vraiment miser sur les solutions à
l'itinérance le cabinet du ministre
lionel carmant responsable du dossier
d'itinérance n'a pas retourné nos
demandes d'entrevue ici jérôme bergeron
radio canada montréal